嘿 美麗的太太
你覺得血糖高跟血糖低
哪個比較危險
大家不是都怕血糖高
錯 血糖低更要命
我認識一位老先生
大概三四十年前的事情
平時他都嚴格
控制他的血糖
按時間打胰島素
血糖降的太低太低了
一條命這樣就沒了
那一天起
我一直提醒病人
別只怕血糖高
更要小心血糖低
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集和你分享的重點
這樣吃白飯
穩定血糖防截肢
吃糙米卻越吃越虛
加它一起煮顧脾胃
減肥少吃飯瘦更快
小心
引發這些難以預料到的後果
這樣吃白飯
穩定血糖防截肢
各位糖友們你知道嗎
台灣每年
有6000-7000位糖友
因為腳足部的潰瘍
傷口惡化
有一成到兩成
連小腿以上都被截肢了
一旦截肢
死亡率還會更增高
5年之內死亡率高達70%
比中風還可怕
這麼恐怖
好好的一個人
怎麼會截肢啊
很多人怕血糖飆高
不敢吃飯 抗拒澱粉
大錯特錯
千萬不要
長期不吃米飯會怎麼樣
你身體的能量不夠
容易飢餓
免疫力也變差
傷口癒合變慢
反而更容易惡化
走向截肢的不歸路
米飯不是萬惡的食物
它能夠補中益氣
養好脾胃
吃白米飯啊
血糖會升高嗎
記住三個撇步
讓你吃得安心
血糖不暴衝
秘訣一
要吃對順序
先吃蛋白質
蔬菜
再澱粉
這樣吃
血糖上升比較慢
胰臟的壓力也比較小
有一個醫生啊
他推薦
先吃肉再吃菜最後才吃飯
三十多年的時間他發現
他發現先吃蛋白質
對血糖的控制
是很關鍵的
為什麼呢
蛋白質進入消化系統之後
會刺激腸道荷爾蒙
和胰島素的分泌
讓身體做準備
像白米
或者是醣類啊之類
進來的時候呢
血糖比較不會
突然的升高
也能夠
減輕胰臟的壓力
秘訣2
吃飯不要煮得太軟爛
為什麼
米飯煮得太爛
糊化的程度
就比較來的高
讓血糖上升的速度
就加快
所以煮飯的時候
不要加太多水
保持吃起來
有點QQ的口感比較好
幫助減緩
血糖上升的速度
最後一個撇步
慢慢吃
血糖不會急著往上飆
吃太快會讓醣類快速吸收
血糖突然的飆高
每一口多咬
那麼兩下子
配合著細嚼慢嚥
穩定血糖
才讓腸胃更輕鬆
糖尿病病友
一餐可以吃多少飯
糖友或者是血糖偏高的人啊
建議每一餐
你可以吃大約半碗飯
也就是大約八十公克的樣子
別忘了
一定要搭配
蛋白質 蔬菜
正確的順序
加慢慢的吃
這樣才能夠
真正的穩定血糖
糖友們看完這一集
明天你就可以這樣吃
再教你一個
吃飯控血糖的吃法
冷飯真能降血糖
1個體質別吃
聽說飯放涼了
然後再吃
這樣血糖才不會飆高
你媽媽不就這樣子嗎
她都喜歡吃冷的
是真的
白飯煮熟放涼以後
會產生所謂的抗性澱粉
不容易被小腸吸收
血糖升的慢
還能被腸道的益菌發酵
增加飽足感
不只是白飯喔
冷的芋頭 地瓜也有效喔
2015年
亞太臨床營養學期刊它證實
說把白飯煮熟
放涼以後再加熱
餐後血糖反應明顯的降低
擔心血糖高的人
你可以這樣吃吃看喔
提醒你
有一種人
不要吃冷飯比較好
脾胃虛寒的人
你有脾胃虛寒的症狀的話呢
喝涼水會拉肚子
手腳冰冷
沒胃口
容易累
那就不適合吃冷飯
來控制血糖
熱飯 暖胃才更養生
吃糙米卻越吃越虛
加它一起煮顧脾胃
許多糖友他吃糙米
吃了肚子都脹脹的
整天都這樣沒精神
對 沒有精神
有些人怕血糖飆高
會改吃糙米飯
那什麼人不能吃糙米呢
如果有這種現象
脹氣 拉肚子
感覺到虛累累的這種人
你可能就是脾胃偏虛
吸收不了
這麼粗硬的米
就不適合再繼續吃糙米
脾胃偏虛的人
我建議你
白米加糙米一起煮
白米補氣 顧脾胃
糙米能夠提供纖維 礦物質
這樣兩種米一起吃
比較不會傷脾胃
不用擔心血糖太高
白米不是糖友的敵人
它是最養人的米
本草綱目裡頭說
粳米是世間第一補人之物
尤其是對脾胃虛弱
中年以後
氣血不足的人來說
白米飯反而是容易吸收
是最補的糧食
少吃飯沒力氣
小心它默默流失
你為了保持身材
每一餐飯
都吃很少很少的飯嗎
站起來感覺到小腿沒力
爬樓梯會軟腳
這就是因為你吃飯吃得太少
肌肉流失得快
很多人以為多吃蛋白質
不吃飯就會長肌肉
錯
肌肉合成除了蛋白質
還需要碳水化合物
來幫助它燃燒
飯吃太少
身體就會把蛋白質
拿去當作能量來用
最後發生什麼事
你知道嗎
肌肉被拿去用了
那肌肉不就變少了嗎
這個時候肌肉會掉了很多
體力也變得差了很多
代謝下降人就更虛
老得更快
中醫說脾主肌肉
白飯能夠
補中益氣 養脾胃
你長期不吃
或吃太少的米飯
脾胃沒有足夠的原料
沒有辦法製造氣血
肌肉就越掉越快
當肌肉不夠力的時候
就容易跌跤
容易骨折
骨折會大大提高死亡率
最嚴重的是根據統計
長者髖部骨折後
一年內有
三成的死亡率
這代表什麼意思
等於是每十個人髖部骨折
有三個人
會在一年之內過世
可怕不可怕
我再說一次
白飯不是
讓你變胖的兇手
反而是你養命的救援糧食
不要因為怕胖
而不吃米飯
適量吃白飯讓你不虛弱
肌肉有力更長壽
白飯是天然養髮素
長期不吃米飯水腫濕氣多
很多人為了減肥
執行生酮飲食
低碳飲食
白飯都不敢吃幾口
長期不吃米飯會怎麼樣呢
人還沒瘦成女神
先水腫 氣虛 頭髮狂掉
看著老相就像個阿嬤了
怎麼說
我來舉一位女明星的例子
她以前為了瘦身
幾乎餐餐都吃
生菜沙拉 雞胸肉
吃到身體太寒
出現手腳冰冷 水腫
過敏的問題 都出現了
後來看過中醫師以後
才知道自己長期用錯方式
來對待身體
中醫師告訴她
白米是最優質的蛋白質
能補氣 去濕氣
她改成三餐吃白飯之後
不只是水腫改善了
連胖回來的三公斤
也瘦回去了
體重更是回到了
差不多50公斤的標準身材
不只如此
白飯可是你維持髮量豐盈
烏黑的大功臣喔
研究發現
連續三個月不吃白米
有67%的人會出現掉頭髮
不吃白飯為什麼會掉髮呢
白米有鋅 鐵 硒
還有維他命B7
它們都是幫助頭髮生長
和製造黑色素的催化劑
是頭髮必須要有的
一種營養素
而且長期不吃碳水化合物
血糖也會受到影響
變得大起大落
有一種激素
叫做壓力激素
就會爆衝
毛囊就提早休眠
加速掉髮
髮際線開始往後退
人看起來就老10歲
吃對碳水化合物也就是醣類
活得久又健康
哈佛大學追蹤近45萬人
發現到每天吃碳水化合物
佔總熱量50%~55%的人
壽命最長
死亡的風險最低
吃太多碳水化合物
也就是70%以上的
或吃太少的碳水化合物
40%以下的
反而他們的壽命更短
我們拿50歲的人來舉例
吃對碳水化合物的人
壽命預期是還有33.1年
吃太少呢
壽命只剩下29.1年
整整少活了4年
少活4年你願意嗎
不要
你應該還想和你愛的人
活到120歲吧
對啊
研究顯示啊
那些拼命吃低醣飲食
用肉用乳酪來代替飯的人
反而血脂肪飆高
心血管風險會增高
早死的機率就更高
所以話不能亂講
飯不能亂戒
適量的吃飯
才能活得又長又健康